[Musique]
dès 2024 et pour la modique somme de 50
mille dollars zh la société world view
vous permettra de vous envoler dans la
stratosphère et d'admirer un panorama
époustouflant depuis une capsule capsule
qui atteindra les 40 kilomètres
d'altitude grâce à un ballon d'hélium
géant que vous voyez juste ici ça a
l'air pas mal pour la première fois
cette équipe de tournage russe s'apprête
à toucher les étoiles pas celle
d'hollywood mais celle de l'espace
l'actrice lou lee ap racing et le
réalisateur clim pitch enhco aidé par un
cosmonaute sont montés à bord de la
station spatiale internationale pour
tourner le premier film en orbite tout
était nouveau pour nous aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression de rêver
[Musique]
l'échec à pied ou en nature
on adore un paiement sans contact depuis
la stratosphère c'est une start up
française qui a envoyé sa propre carte
bancaire et un terminal de paiement à
près de 40 km du sol terrestre pour
payer note de 45 euros un hôtel belge
si vous vous demandez
vous n'êtes pas seul pour l'entreprise
parisienne désormais détentrice de cette
première mondiale ce paiement sans
contact n'est pas sans intérêt elle veut
y voir un symbole de l'explosion et de
la facilité de cette pratique dernier
jour de la fashion week de paris d
milito d'extinction rébellion ont fait
irruption pendant des filets de louis
vuitton au louvre et pour dénoncer donc
l'impact de l'industrie de la mode et
des sorties en vous le voyez par les
agents de sécurité et surconsommation
c'est ce qu'on pouvait dire sur la fille
a dit on des militantes une fois élu
président la république je m'attacherai
à réparer les dégâts du progrès
je ferai ainsi voté une loi interdisant
le téléphone portable aux moins de 18
ans au lieu d'un ter réagir les yeux
rivés sur leur écran du matin au soir et
du soir au matin les enfants et les
adolescents doivent apprendre regarder
le monde et s'ouvrir à la transmission
[Applaudissements]
en bref
tu t'es monde avec une poussette tarière
calvet par mon père et mon frère est
dans ce magasin journaux dans le 7e
arrondissement il y avait aussi des fans
très belle très grande des mecs
vachement bien sapés tout ça et
l'injustice sociale me rendait fou
points donc avec cette histoire recteur
je me suis dit si je réussi à canaliser
les femmes pour me sourire dans la rue
c'est pour ça qu'en les fameux souris
dans l'eure une femme ça me suis mesuré
dans la rue je suis fou tu vois je n'ai
je fais ce métier pour situer de très
jolies il ya de très jolis chalets
scheubel classe et sexy mais
je dirais pêcheurs rien tu vas me begeot
non je dirais déçu
mais bien sûr bruno je sens qu'il a
besoin de quelqu'un qui est un peu plus
dans une rectitude morale tu te noies ça
veut dire que vous avez un rectum
[Applaudissements]
vous dites oui pour moi tout le monde
doit avoir la parole et quand je vous
dis est ce que tout le monde se vaut
vous me répondez oui et j'imagine que
vous êtes déjà posé la question elle est
un peu cliché mais évidemment on se la
pose est ce que à l'époque en 33 en
allemagne vous vous diriez est-ce qu'il
faut inviter horn hitler non mais c'est
à dire est ce que vous dites d'ailleurs
vous dites on peut s'asseoir vous citez
vous dites on peut s'asseoir à la table
du diable mais si on a une longue
cuillère eric zemmour reviendra sur
votre plateau bien sûr qu'il viendra sur
mon plateau et dans ces cas là il vient
avec les chroniqueurs où il vient avec
des athlètes aigle il avec les
chroniqueurs voilà où on c'est sûr qu'on
fera une émission et qu'eric zemmour on
recevra tout le monde mais ont tous à
votre avis y vont tous vouloir venir sur
votre plateau côté on dit souvent en
concurrence aussi
[Rires]
le cumul est possible c'est pareil c'est
la famille mais vous dites aussi qu'il
ya un côté sympa chez tout le monde et
c'est vrai que enfin je vais peut-être
avoir l'air grotesque en disant ça mais
j'imagine que hitler si vous de parler
juste de chiens ou non de bouffe il peut
être sympa là c'est qu'il a cédé sa
place est dans mes lacets quelqu'un non
mais ça vous parler d'un truc
irrécupérable ça n'a rien à voir moi je
parle des gens que deux jeux j'invite
des joueurs entre eux ils sont bons mais
ils sont dangereux rival les gens l'ont
suffisamment aimé oui oui portée aux
pauvres raid en mai c'est une vraie
question est mais non mais là
franchement la plage de trou franchement
que ça n'a rien à voir zemmour est
obsédé par l'immigration vous vous êtes
obsédé par eric zemmour alors gasquet
mais expliquez nous mais pour titiller
le détestent depuis le premier jour
c'est comme si j'avais entendu d'abord
il m'a toujours pris de haut je pense
qu'il m'a toujours considéré quand même
beaucoup de provinces ensuite il ne
s'est jamais comporté moins dans les
cénacles que j'ai fréquentés comme un
journaliste il a toujours été à égalité
avec les hommes politiques il a toujours
dit ce qu'ils pensaient de bien pour la
france comme la montagne pelée la
plupart des volcans explosifs peuvent
rester endormi pendant des années
voire des siècles
avant de se réveiller
j'ai toujours trouvé artificielle bête
utilisant abusivement l'histoire en la
trafiquants seul trafiquant de
l'histoire il est un petit français je
pense qu'ils n'aiment pas l'histoire de
la france entre en scène qui dit le
contraire il veut sauver la france c'est
l'anti france zemmour merci beaucoup à
hidalgo d'avoir été notre candidat c'est
à vous notre candidat
c'est validé je me demandais je vous
demanderais si cyril vous seriez ok pour
peut-être monteur en voiture avec anne
hidalgo et moi et puis on monte on lui
pose les questions qui fâchent regarde
un petit peu son défi
voiture et 40 millions d'automobilistes
non mais en s'appuyant chasserait vous
êtes quand même alors je peux je peux je
dis toujours la vérité sur vous êtes
quand même très gonflé j'ai vendu 7 et
idées pour ses news et vous êtes en
train de revendre à cyril hanouna savez
quand vous ratez votre vie vous n'avez
plus que l'amertume vous trouver des
coupables et des responsables parce que
c'est toujours il ya toujours un couple
quand on est ratée il ya toujours un
responsable qui n'est pas le rater
c'est de la faute
à chaque fois c'est le plat
c'est dur pour tout le monde ça sera
toujours durer tant mieux c'est grâce à
ça qu'on comptera via des montages dit
n'importe quoi j'ai fini je ne profite
pas aux places
moi j'en demande toujours encore un peu
[Rires]
les voilà
content de venir merci d'être venus